[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur public sénat d'ici la fin
2022 154 des 534 personnes actuellement
détenues pour des actes de terrorisme en
lien avec la mouvance islamiste seront
libérés dans ce contexte le sénat a
adopté hier un texte instaurant des
mesures de sûreté à l'encontre des
auteurs d'infractions terroristes à
l'issue de leur peine objectif renforcer
le suivi et prévenir la récidive je vous
propose de regarder les débats en séance
et on se retrouve après madame la
présidente madame et messieurs les
sénateurs
la proposition de loi que vous examinez
est très sensible elle s'efforce de
répondre à la problématique des
personnes condamnées pour des actes de
terrorisme dont certains présentent
toujours une situation de dangerosité en
fin de peine
sur ces questions j'ai évolué vais vous
le savez monsieur le président de la
commission permettez moi tout d'abord de
rappeler quelques données factuelles 260
personnes sont actuellement détenues en
france après une condamnation pour
infraction terroriste en lien avec la
mouvance islamiste
parmi ceux ci certains purgent des
peines correctionnelles de plusieurs
années principalement entre 7 et 10 ans
prononcée pour beaucoup après 2012
outre ces détenus condamnés
deux cent cinquante deux personnes sont
en détention provisoire après avoir été
mise en examen pour des actes de
terrorisme seront jugés dans les mois ou
les années qui viennent puisque 49
procès terroristes se dérouleront d'ici
parmi les condamnés 31
seront libérés en 2020 62 en 2021 50 en
2022 après avoir exécuté leur peine les
lois du 3 juin puis du 21 juillet 2016
ont supprimé les crédits de réduction de
peine pour les terroristes et restreint
leur accès à la libération
conditionnelle
mais ces lois ont sans doute repousser
la difficulté voire l'ont renforcé
puisque ce sont ces mêmes détenus qui
vont prochainement quitter la détention
sorties sèches
selon l'expression convenue je
souhaitais faire ce bref rappel car il
résume je crois le défi qui est le nôtre
d'apporter une réponse pénale au
terrorisme bâtie depuis 1986 notre
dispositif judiciaire de réponse à la
menace terroriste est équilibré il
repose sur un dispositif centralisée
avec des aménagements procéduraux ce
cadre encore été complétée l'an dernier
avec la création d'un parc est autonome
spécialisée le pnt dans son oeuvre
normative le législateur a toujours
cherché à articuler la spécificité
qu'impose une criminalité complexe dont
la finalité est l'effondrement de notre
modèle sociétal et nos valeurs
démocratiques
c'est en ayant à l'esprit c'est
impérieux besoin d' équilibre que vous
devez je crois aborder ces débats un
travail important est réalisé dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires afin de
prévenir la radicalisation des détenus
et de freiner tout prosélytisme délétère
plusieurs rapports en ont rendu compte
je pense notamment en rapport des
députés diar et pouya sur les services
publics face à la radicalisation qui
comprend des propositions destinées à
renforcer le suivi des personnes
radicaliser je pense aussi à celui de la
contrôleur contrôleur pardonnez-moi
général des lieux de privation de
liberté sur la prise en charge
pénitentiaire des personnes radicalise
et le respect des droits fondamentaux la
remise en liberté de détenus condamnés
potentiellement toujours radicaux lee
radicaliser en dépit du travail réalisé
appelle cependant une réponse nous
devons tout mettre en oeuvre pour
garantir la sûreté de nos concitoyens
cette majorité s'y est déjà attaché
ainsi le dispositif de la loi sylt du 30
octobre 2017 a ouvert la possibilité de
soumettre ces personnes à une mesure de
contrôle administratif et de
surveillance mais limité à un nom la
durée de ces mesures administratives
paraître aujourd'hui insuffisante
pourtant soumettre des personnes ayant
purgé leur peine un nouveau résume
judiciaire restrictive de la liberté
appelle à la vigilance
il faut il faut se garder de l'illusion
d'une justice prédictive chimère qui est
la négation de l'idée même de justice et
de réhabilitation nous devons veiller à
ce que les mesures que nous élaborons
n'enferme pas davantage les condamnés
dans leur mise entre au pire au lieu de
permettre à leur réinsertion qui doit
rester notre objectif principal le
travail de l'assemblée nationale puis de
votre commission des lois s'appuyant sur
un avis très étayé du conseil d'état a
permis je crois de dégager une solution
d'équilibré
l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
un produit dans le code de procédure
pénale un dispositif permettant au juge
judiciaire d'imposer des mesures de
sûreté aux personnes condamnées pour des
faits de terrorisme ayant purgé leur
peine d'emprisonnement
les mesures de sûreté doivent respecter
le principe résultant de l'article 9 de
la déclaration de 1789 selon lequel la
liberté ne saurait être entravée par une
rigueur qui ne soit nécessaire
en effet le législateur doit concilier
d'une part la prévention des atteintes à
l'ordre public et d'autre part
l'exercice des libertés
constitutionnellement garantis à cet
égard il convient d'être vigilant sur le
caractère adapté nécessaire
et proportionnée du dispositif nous
sommes sur une ligne de crête prendre
des mesures qui permettent d'assurer la
protection des français sans en adopter
qui ne serait pas strictement
nécessaires
le texte que vous vous apprêtez à voter
est donc un texte d'équilibré
je le redis j'invite par conséquent
votre assemblée à la prudence surtout
durcissement du texte voté par
l'assemblée nationale alors que le
conseil d'état a appelé notre attention
sur ce point s'agissant des garanties
attachées à la nouvelle mesure je tiens
à rappeler les éléments suivants le
concept de dangerosité n'est pas
étranger à notre droit je rappelle que
les mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et de surveillance déclaré
conforme à la constitution repose sur un
tel concept
le nouveau dispositif constitue une
mesure restrictive de liberté et non
privative de liberté
s'impliquant à des personnes condamnées
définitivement le placement sous
surveillance électronique mobile de la
personne est soumis à son consentement
l'évolution de la dangerosité des
condamnés susceptibles de faire l'objet
de ces nouvelles mesures de sûreté sera
réalisée par la commission
pluridisciplinaire des mesures de sûreté
qui saura prendre en charge ce sujet
complexe celui de la dangerosité
grâce à l'ensemble des compétences de
chacun de ses membres et leur
spécialisation dans l'appréciation de la
dangerosité d'une personne
enfin c'est l'autorité judiciaire et
elle seule
il sera compétente afin de prononcer le
cas échéant de telles mesures de sûreté
et les suivre tout au long de leur durée
cette décision interviendra à l'issue
d'un débat contradictoire et un appel
des parties sera toujours possible
enfin pour l'avenir il serait essentiel
de réaliser une évaluation des
dispositifs de prévention de la récidive
terroristes dans leur ensemble
la complexité actuelle peut en effet
nuire à l'efficacité de l'action de
l'état
il est nécessaire de proposer une remise
à plat des dispositifs existants afin
que l'empilement actuelle retrouve une
cohérence et une lisibilité d'ensemble
c'est au prix d'une telle évaluation que
l'action de l'état trouvera sa pleine
efficacité son sens et sa cohérence
la parole est à madame jacqueline
eustache brinio rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour dix minutes
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
le sénat est appelé aujourd'hui à
examiner une proposition de loi
instaurant des mesures de sûreté à
l'encontre des auteurs d'infractions
terroristes à l'issue de leur peine
déposée par madame yaël boon peavey est
adopté par l'assemblée nationale le 23
juin dernier
ce texte a pour ambition d'apporter une
réponse à l'enjeu majeur que représente
pour la sécurité de notre pays la
libération de plus de 150 terroriste
d'ici la fin de l'année 2022
il créé à cet effet une nouvelle mesure
de sûreté
sur le fond notre commission des lois ne
pouvait qu'accueillir favorablement ce
texte il répond en effet à un constat
qu'elle a elle même formulé au moins de
février dernier à l'occasion du bilan de
la loi 6
une proposition de loi similaire à celle
que nous examinons aujourd'hui à
d'ailleurs été proposée par le président
philippe bas et notre collègue
marc-philippe daubresse dès le début du
mois de mars
je me réjouis donc que le gouvernement
ait pris l'initiative d'inscrire le
sujet à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée
la proposition de loi pour principal
objet de créer une nouvelle mesure de
sûreté
dédiée à la prise en charges des
condamnés terroristes qui sortent de
détention elle prévoit également de
faire du suivi socio-judiciaire une
peine complémentaire obligatoire
ce texte va combler un vide juridique
dénoncé par de nombreux acteurs de
terrain le législateur a considéré mme
ampe renforcer l'arsenal anti terroriste
au cours des dernières années mais il
s'est concentré sur la répression et le
régime des peines sans anticiper la
question du suivi à l'issue de
l'exécution des peines nous sommes donc
dans une station paradoxal est peu
satisfaisante les individus condamnés
pour des faits terroristes sont
aujourd'hui les plus suivis en détention
mais les moins accompagnés au moment de
leur libération
bien entendu il ne s'agit pas de dire
que rien n'existe mais les outils temps
judiciaire qu'administratif se révèle un
complet et inadaptée à l'enjeu
c'est pourquoi la commission a approuvé
le principe de la mesure de sûreté
créée par cette proposition de loi
toutefois je sais que la mesure suscite
des craintes notamment sur sa
constitutionnalité
y compris dans cet hémicycle à cet égard
je tiens à insister sur un point la
mesure crée et ne constitue en aucun cas
une peine après la peine
il s'agit d'une mesure de sûreté au sens
de la jurisprudence défini par le
conseil constitutionnel
en effet elle n'a pas pour objet de
sanctionner mais bien de prévenir la
récidive et la commission de nouveaux
actes de terrorisme elle ne se fonde pas
sur la culpabilité de la personne mais
sur la dangerosité évalué à l'issue de
la période de détention
n'oublions pas qu'en 2008 le conseil
constitutionnel a déjà admis l'existence
de mesures de même nature et validé la
rétention et la surveillance de sûreté
ceci dit il est de notre responsabilité
de trouver le point d'équilibré entre
sécurité et liberté
nous y sommes évidemment à force et nous
nous sommes efforcés de travailler sur
ce sujet à la commission des lois la
semaine dernière il s'agit d'un exercice
difficile mais je crois que nous y
sommes parvenus nous avons donc apporté
une série de garanties pour assurer la
constitutionnalité de ce texte
nous avons tout d'abord encadré le champ
d'application de la mesure en la
limitant aux personnes condamnés aux
peines les plus lourdes supérieure à
cinq ans d'emprisonnement
il s'agit de répondre à une exigence
constitutionnelle
à l'instar de ce qui est prévu pas pour
la rétention et la surveillance de
sûreté
dans le même état d'esprit nous avons
précisé l'articulation de la mesure crée
avec les dispositifs existants il
s'agissait tout d'abord de garantir que
la mesure ne soit prononcée que
lorsqu'elle est strictement nécessaire
et adaptée pour suivre ces profils il
s'agissait également de garantir une
articulation fluide avec les mesures
administratives notamment les nids casse
enfin nous avons apporté plusieurs
ajustements à la procédure
même si le texte de l'assemblée
nationale était déjà équilibré sur ce
point et garantissez le respect des
droits
la défense notre principale modification
porte sur le contenu des réquisitions du
procureur antiterroriste
il nous est pas il nous est apparu
indispensable que ces réquisitions
s'appuient sur des éléments non
seulement circonstancié mais également
actuelle pour assurer la stricte
nécessité et la proportionnalité de la
mesure demandée
je suis bien consciente que ces
modifications peuvent sembler
restreindre les possibilités de
surveillance
nous avons toutefois intérêt à ce que la
mesure soit solide
en cas d'inconstitutionnalité c'est tout
le dispositif qui seraient fragilisés ce
qu'aucun d'entre nous ne souhaite
parallèlement à ce souci d'équilibré la
commission a cherché à s'assurer du
caractère opérationnel de la mesure il
m'a été indiqué qu'après le texte adopté
par l'assemblée nationale
il y avait quelques interrogations à ce
sujet et en particulier sur la plaque y
lier pardon de 7 du texte pour surmonter
ces difficultés nous avons adopté quatre
modifications
il était tout d'abord essentiel de
réviser le champ d'application de la
mesure dans le texte de l'assemblée
nationale les critères de dangerosité
était apprécié par deux éléments d'une
part le risque élevé très élevé de
récidive
d'autre part l'adhésion persistance à
une entreprise tendant à troubler
gravement l'ordre public par
l'intimidation et la terreur
ce deuxième critique ce deuxième critère
était à notre sens très triste trop
restrictif il se rapprochait de la
définition de l'infraction d'association
de malfaiteurs terroristes qui rendait
la mesure quasiment inapplicable
autrement dit si ce critère était
remplie alors il aurait été possible
d'engager une nouvelle procédure
judiciaire à l'encontre de la personne
nous avons donc atténuer légèrement sa
définition en visant l'addition
persistante à une idéologie ou à des
thèses incitant la commission d'actes de
terrorisme plutôt que l'adhésion à une
entreprise terroriste
la deuxième modification principale
concerne la durée de la mesure et des
buts et ont prévu une durée d'un an
renouvelable dans la nuit de 5 ans ou de
dix ans en cas de condamnation pour
crime ou délit grave
cette durée d'un an
elle a jugé peu râpeux opérationnel par
les acteurs judiciaires
elle imposerait d'engager la procédure
de renouvellement
moins d'un mois après le prononcé de la
mesure j'ai donc proposé à la commission
de porter cette durée à deux ans comme
le prévoyait la proposition de loi du
président bas et de marc philippe
daubresse
j'ajoute que la personne conservera à
tout moment la possibilité de demander
la main levée de la mesure ce qui me
paraît garantir un équilibre
satisfaisant
en troisième le la commission a réécrit
l'obligation de placement sous
surveillance électronique mobile car la
rédaction adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale
la rendait peu opérationnels en effet
contrairement à une idée reçue le
bracelet électronique n'est pas un
dispositif phillies utilisés pour suivre
en permanence et en temps réel une
personne il ne sert qu'à assurer le
respect d'une autre mesure limitant la
liberté d'aller et de venir
par exemple une interdiction de paraître
dans certains lieux lançant des acteurs
que nous avons entendues ont été
unanimes sur ce point tel qu'il était
rédigé le placement sous surveillance
électronique était et inapplicable
c'est pourquoi la commission associés
l'obscène aux autres obligations de
surveillance
autrement dit elle a prévu que le
bracelet soit prononcée pour contrôler
le respect des autres obligations en
particulier l'interdiction de paraître
l'interdiction de fréquenter certaines
personnes extérieures nous avons en
revanche jugé nécessaire de supprimer la
possibilité de cumuler le monde
le placement sur surveillance et le
pointage qui pourrait durer dix propos
qui pourraient être jugée
disproportionnée par le conseil
constitutionnel
enfin la commission a renforcé le
contenu de la mesure créée elle a d'une
part renforcer le volet surveillance de
la mesure en insérant deux obligations
complémentaires l'interdiction de se
livrer à l'activité au cours de laquelle
l'infraction était commise et
l'interdiction de détenir ou de porter
une arme
elle a d'autre part renforcer le volet
d'accompagnement à la réinsertion qui
était quasiment absent du texte proposé
et adopté par les députés sur ce volet
il a été prévu un suivi par les services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et de
probation
parallèlement ont suivi qui sera opéré
par le juge de l'application des peines
la commission a également introduit
une nouvelle obligation d'exercer une
activité professionnelle ou de suivre
une formation
nous avons répondu sur ce point une
demande forte des acteurs de terrain
n'oublions pas que l'intérêt d'une
mesure judiciaire par rapport une mesure
administrative est bien de prévenir la
récidive non seulement par des mesures
de surveillance mais également par des
mesures d'assistance et je suis
particulièrement attaché à cet apport
qui je le crois sans est nécessaire si
nous souhaitons gérer efficacement ses
profils effectivement compliqué pour
garantir l'efficacité de l'ensemble de
ses obligations et faciliter leur
contrôle la commission a également
introduit un article 1er bis pour
prévoir l'inscription des obligations de
la mesure de sûreté au fichier des
personnes recherchées
face au défi du terrorisme le sénat
toujours fait preuve de responsabilité
dès 2014 il a pris l'initiative de
plusieurs évolutions législatives qui
ont permis de renforcer considérablement
notre arsenal anti terroriste dans le
strict respect des libertés
individuelles
c'est ce même esprit qui doit
aujourd'hui nous guider nous a mené
collectivement approuvé ce texte doter
les pouvoirs publics de nouveaux moyens
adaptés à la prise en charge du
terroriste sortant de détention est une
priorité pour la sécurité des français
c'est ce que je propose de faire ce soir
même la présidente monsieur le garde des
sceaux mam la rapporteure monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
chers collègues sont 43 donc 143
personnes condamnées pour des actes de
terrorisme vont sortir des prisons
françaises d'ici 2022 et trente-et-une
dès cette année 10 elle garde des sceaux
à l'instant un second chiffres jusqu'à
100% de 39 % à 100 % c'est le taux de
récidive des djihadistes d'après le
centre d'analysé du terrorisme et je
crois que c'est une données factuelles
sur laquelle il est possible de
s'appuyer et ce double constat factuel
pose aux législateurs la question des
moyens juridiques pour répondre d'une
part ce sujet traite d'un enjeu majeur
de sécurité publique soulignée par les
professionnels auditionnés ils ont
exprimé une crainte une vraie crainte
qui n'est pas théorique sur la situation
des personnes détenues amené à sortir
dans les trois ans
d'autre part il résulte des travaux des
deux assemblées qui ont identifié une
incomplétude et unis d'adaptation des
dispositifs de suivi et de surveillance
en vigueur le président de notre
commission des lois philippe bach avait
déposé une proposition de loi en amont
de nos collègues du groupe la raim à
l'assemblée nationale qui partageait le
même objectif que le texte que nous
imaginons aujourd'hui eh oui monsieur le
président il faut rendre à philippe base
qui appartient à philippe la présente
proposition par donc bien d'une réalité
alarmante et répond à un enjeu clair
apporter une réponse à un manque
ces lacunes ont déjà été mentionné je ne
m'y attarderai pas elles tiennent
notamment à l'année applicabilité du
suivi socio judiciaire ou personnes
condamnées pour des faits commis avant
elles tiennent également à
l'inadéquation de la surveillance
judiciaire
les personnes condamnées pour des actes
de terrorisme ayant été exclu en 2016
des dispositifs de réduction de peine
dans le cadre de laquelle s'applique
cette surveillance
au plan administratif les mesures
individuelles de contrôle et de
surveillance apparaissez pour leur part
insuffisante par leur durée limitée à 12
à 12 mois
et en ce qu'elles n'offrent pas d'
accompagnement à la réinsertion sur la
réinsertion
le travail a été fait il est constitue
d'ailleurs un point essentiel 2 du
travail mené sur ce texte en matière de
durée bien évidemment il est attractif
d'envisager une prolongation
elle pose néanmoins fortement la
question de la constitutionnalité d'une
durée de 24 mois la présente proposition
de loi permet donc de répondre utilement
à ce vide paradoxal est préoccupant elle
permet par son article premier de créer
une nouvelle mesure de sûreté qui donne
la faculté aux juges dans le respect du
contradictoire d'appliquer des
obligations en matière de surveillance
et de suivi aux condamnés pour
terrorisme
présentant à l'issue de leur peine une
particulière dangerosité tel que nous
l'avons indiqué en commission
elle renforce utilement dans un article
de adopté conforme par notre commission
la mise en
du suivi socio-judiciaire en prévoyant
une automaticité de son prononcé et elle
prévoit enfin après l'adoption
d'amendements ce sens en commission et
l'inscription bienvenue de certaines
obligations de la mesure de sûreté au
fichier des personnes recherchées ainsi
que l'application du dispositif dans les
territoires ultramarins chers collègues
ça a été dit le présent texte nous place
effectivement ou sur le garde des sceaux
sur une ligne de crête en matière de
libertés publiques
l'utilité du dispositif ne saurait
éluder la nécessité de s'assurer du
respect des principes fondamentaux de
notre droit et notamment en matière
pénale certains sur ses bancs ont
exprimé la crainte que les obligations
de la mesure de certaines s'avèrent être
des peines après la peine contrevenants
par là même au principe du non bis in
idem non seulement l'avis du conseil
d'état affirme très clairement que les
mesures visées par la ppl ont
exclusivement la nature de mesures de
sûreté
non seulement le conseil constitutionnel
n'exclut pas par principe la possibilité
pour le législateur de créer des mesures
de sûreté mais les rapporteurs à
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat ce
sont justement employé à renforcer les
garanties du dispositif et sa rigueur
absolument nécessaire je pense aux
modifications introduites à l'assemblée
tenant par exemple la réduction de la
durée maximale global de la mesure de
sûreté
tirant les conséquences des observations
de l'avis du conseil d'état ces
modifications conservé par notre
commission renforce l'assise juridique
du dispositif
je pense également aux garanties
introduite en matière de placement sous
surveillance électronique mobile tenant
au consentement de la personne et la
réduction de la fréquence de l'
obligation de pointage
l'enjeu pour la majorité à l'assemblée
était bien et nous aurons je le crois
l'occasion d'y revenir dans les débats
entre les deux chambres de concilier le
caractère opérationnel avec la sécurité
juridique du dispositif
notre rapporteur jacqueline eustache
brinio que je salue pour le travail
qu'elle a menée a également procédé à
des clarifications bienvenue quand à
l'articulation de la mesure de sûreté
institué avec les autres dispositifs de
suivi
et de surveillance en vigueur en portant
en s'intéressant sur la durée initiale
elle nous a indiqué vouloir veiller à
l'indispensable proportionnalité de la
mesure et à sa constitutionnalité
nous y reviendrons certainement
finalement et les éléments que je viens
de mentionner l'illustrent bien un
double objectif à guider les travaux nos
deux assemblées l'opérationnalité la
constitutionnalité de la mesure de
sûreté instituts et ils continueront je
le crois a déclaré lisa éclairé des
échanges entre les deux chambres jusqu'à
la commission mixte paritaire qui je
n'en doute pas aboutir à afin de
répondre à l'enjeu de protection de la
société dans le respect de notre état de
droit
bien évidemment le groupe la république
votera ce texte
le groupe la république en marche
absolument
merci de votre attention au bout de six
minutes d'intervention c'est tout à fait
mûr et anjou félicite chers collègues je
vous remercie de votre attention je
remercie chers collègues puisqu'elle
semble partagée merci la parole est à
monsieur stéphane ravier pour 3 minutes
merci
m
bonjour j lente
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues quand on
entend terrorisme
on pense immédiatement au terrorisme
islamiste qui ensanglantent notre pays
depuis de nombreuses années mais il
n'est pas le seul sur le temps de parole
qui m'est accordée je veux apporter par
un instant de silence mon soutien à la
famille d'axel d'aurier cette jolie
jeune femme de 23 ans aide-soignante
tout le portrait de ma propre fille
axelle martyrs victimes d'un terrorisme
du quotidien qui ne dit pas son nom
celui commis par la racaille cette
racaille qui tue les nôtres partout en
france dans le silence de la
bien-pensance l'indifférence de la
classe politique et le mépris des
officines médiatique que l'on me donne
les noms monsieur le ministre que l'on
donne les noms et que la justice frappe
qu'elle frappe fort
depuis la loi de 2008 rue mécanismes de
rétention de sûreté n'a jamais été mis
en oeuvre dans une affaire de terrorisme
depuis l'attentât de charlie hebdo en
2015 votre angélisme a coûté à notre
pays plus de 250 vies il ya quatre ans
le 14 juillet à nice 86 personnes et est
assassiné par un terroriste tunisien
quelques jours plus tard c'était le père
hamel qui était en sang à son tour
assassiné en son église par un jihadiste
de 19 ans adèle khenniche preuve
éclatante et tragique de l'échec d'une
vision idéologique et laxiste de la
justice qui s'est obstiné à voir un
jeune garçon perdu là où son cv indiqué
qu'elle avait à faire un assassin
endoctrinés et déterminer ses leçons du
passé écrite à l'encré du sang des
innocents n'ont pas empêché mme
belloubet d'anticiper la libération de
74 détenus radicaliser soixante quatorze
foyers susceptibles de relancer
l'épidémie de barbarie en france mère
des arts des armes et des lois fille
aînée de l'église l'islamisme est comme
un poisson dans l'eau
pour preuve on apprend que 153 condamné
pour ce même terrorisme vont retrouver
leur liberté dans notre pays cette année
le constat est clair les mesures de
sûreté à l'issue des peines sont
insuffisantes et inadaptées
face à ces barbares il faut être
impitoyable refusé sans aucune exception
le retour des djihadistes condamné à
l'étranger rétablir à perpétuité réelle
déchoir de la nationalité française les
binationaux expulser les étrangers
instaurer un tracking numérique et un
suivi des terroristes avec ou sans leur
consentement permettra d'obtenir un
mécanisme de surêté effectif et efficace
et pour ceux qui auraient commis
l'irréparable si le gign le raid ou
labeyrie nous en aurait rapidement et
définitivement débarrassé ce n'est pas
moi mes chers collègues qui m'en
plaindrais aux antipodes de ces mesures
de bon sens vous avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre vouloir rapatrier en france
les jihadistes ayant fait allégeance à
l'état islamique est condamné à mort en
irak ou en syrie au fond vous êtes resté
dans notre robe d'avocat honoré de
descendre abdelkader mira le président
sera celui de la menace permanente sur
les français avaient eux aussi le
candidat emmanuel macron en avril 2017
voilà un engagement qu'il aura tenu il
rejeté le projet d'inventer un programme
de lutte contre le terrorisme dans la
nuit plus de trois ans ont passé la nuit
n'est assurément pas terminée et le sang
français continue de couler
la parole est à mme adam eliane assassi
pour six minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente
waouh
madame la présidente sur le garde des
sceaux madame la rapporteure mais ce
prix en à commission des lois mes chers
collègues alors pour tout vous dire je
ne vais pas ménagé d'effet de surprise
en vous disant d'emblée que l'ensemble
des membres de mon groupe est opposé à
ce texte non seulement pour les mesures
précise qu'il vise à instaurer mais
aussi et surtout pour la vision de notre
société dont il est porteur car notre
rôle de législateur devrait aussi en
tout cas c'est ce que je pense
consistait à prendre le recul nécessaire
sur les lois que nous faisons et sur
leur cohérence globale
or l'inflation des mesures pénales ces
dernières années et plus que notable
pour témoigner aux état d'urgence
sécuritaire successifs qui ne sont pas
simplement propre au chant du terrorisme
d'ailleurs se succèdent aujourd'hui des
mesures spécifiques pour encadrer la
remise en liberté d'auteurs
d'infractions terroristes ayant purgé
leur peine
après avoir décidé en 2016 exclure ces
condamnés de toute possibilité
d'aménagement de peine on se retrouve
donc aujourd'hui face à la problématique
de leur sortie dite sèche
la question est à présent de savoir
qu'allons nous faire de ces individus
pour qui toutes les mesures prévues lors
de leur peine au niveau carcéral ont
échoué après les quartiers d'évaluation
et de prise en charge de la
radicalisation sur lesquels nous
demandons un rapport au gouvernement par
voie d'amendement
nous créons donc aujourd'hui de nouveaux
espaces carcéraux pour évaluer de
nouveaux ces condamnés afin de décider
si ceux ci présentent un caractère
dangereux pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens ou non alors que les choses
soient claires mon objectif ne diffère
en rien du vôtre protéger nos
concitoyens de tout nouvel acte barbare
est fondamentale à ceci près qu'il
s'accompagne d'un autre type
d'inquiétude au regard de l'accumulation
des dispositifs d'exception de au droit
commun au fil des années
je me demande dans quelle perspective
nous avançons et surtout jusqu'où nous
irons car que nous étions clairement
proposées aujourd'hui ne sachant que
faire de ces individus mais souhaitant
tout de même dissiper toute éventuelle
peurs légitimes ou non nous les
maintenons dans une forme de peine après
la peine en restreignant leur liberté
sur le fondement non pas des actes
qu'ils ont commis
mais des axes qu'on suppose qu'ils
pourraient commettre initialement hormis
la mesure de prise en charge sanitaire
sociale éducative ou psychologique
les mesures prévues prévus n'étaient que
des mesures de contrôle dont l'intérêt
en terme de réinsertion est quasi nulle
nous pouvons reconnaître l'apport de la
commission des lois en ce sens qu'elle a
enrichi le volet réinsertion
pour notre part nous avons toujours été
et nous continuons de lettres opposés
aux mesures de sûreté en général
considérant qu'un individu ayant purgé
sa peine et quitte libre de trouver sa
voie de réinsertion dans notre société
créée en 2008 sous nicolas sarkozy
le principe des mesures de sûreté était
à la base destiné aux condamnés en fin
de peine jugé dangereux pour des motifs
psychiatriques
lors de l'adoption de la rétention de
sûreté les sénatrices et des sénateurs
de mon groupe
alerte et déjà sur les dérives vers une
justice prédictive sous couvert de
prévention au même moment et je suis
très jeu le site rémois aussi le
sénateur badinter dénoncé de son côté
une période sombre pour la justice
insistant sur le brouillard dans lequel
cette détention pour dangerosité hors de
toute infraction allait plonger la
justice dont les fondements étaient
atteints aujourd'hui en pointant avec
force à récidive probable dans voit-on
pas aux condamnés qui ont purgé leur
peine de signal qu'ils sont suspectés
avis est en quelque sorte rejeté de la
république d'autant qu'il faudrait
réaliser une vaste étude sur les risques
réels de récidive des personnes
condamnées pour des actes terroristes en
france la belgique la réaliser et
publier et a publié un rapport cette
année et elle révèle que le taux de
récidive de ces détenus est très faible
comparé à celui des détenus dits
classiques 3 % contre 50 pour
aussi dans la mesure où la spécificité
des crimes et délits terroristes
reste à démontrer en terme de passage à
l'acte et de réitération
n'aurait-il pas été plus efficace de
maintenir ces condamnés dans le droit
commun et de leur permettre ainsi
l'accession aux aménagements de peine
comprenons nous bien des aménagements
préparer adapté à leur personnalité et
individualisé et dont tout manquement
pourrait être rapidement repéré ou
sanctionnés cela ne serait-il pas plus à
même de prévenir la récidive que des
mesures de pure contrôle et de
stigmatisation
vraiment je m'interroge en outre nous
pensons que ce que révèle cette
proposition de loi c'est quand même
l'échec du temps pénitentiaire et les
vraies questions auxquelles ce texte ne
répond pas sont nos nombreuses autant
que faire se peut comment prévenir les
actes de terrorisme quels moyens par
exemple pour nos services de
renseignement comment réinsérer dans
notre société des individus condamnés
pour de tels faits sûrement pas en les
obligeant pendant plusieurs années à se
rendre jusqu'à trois fois par semaine
dans un commissariat pour justifier leur
présence obstacle évident à la reprise
une vie active et socialisante c'est
pourtant l'une des obligations que tend
à mettre en oeuvre cette proposition de
loi et dont nous proposerons la
suppression quels moyens sont donnés aux
services pénitentiaires pour le suivi
des personnes condamnées et quelles sont
les modalités de suivi alors de nombreux
rapports ont été faits sur le sujet du
traitement de la radicalisation
notamment d'initiative parlementaire et
à chaque fois ceux ci ont retenu
l'attention de la chancellerie mais
jamais jamais aucune recommandation n'a
trouvé sa concrétisation avec la mise en
oeuvre de mesures idoines
avec cette proposition de loi une fois
encore aucune recommandation faite les
prises en cause
jose la question pourquoi monsieur le
garde des sceaux lors de vos premières
questions d'actualité dans nos murs vous
évoquez le défi le difficile et vous
l'avez refait équilibre à tenir entre
liberté et sûreté dans le cadre de
mesures post pénale cet équilibre est il
satisfaisant selon vous avec les mesures
qui ne sont aujourd'hui proposées une
citation la punition n'a jamais
constitué un mode de 10
lyon et n'importe quelles mains ce
réconfort à une victime déjà morte
explique l'un des personnages dans
l'introduction de mignot une minorité
minorité arrivé au report de file
philippe qu'annick de la fiction à la
réalité
le pas est presque franchi avec les
dispositions que propose ce texte
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission madame la rapporteure chers
collègues tous ici nous soutenons la
lutte de notre nation contre le
terrorisme tous ici nous pensons
victimes à leurs familles à leurs amis
dont parfois nous sommes tous ici sommes
profondément reconnaissants à nos
soldats et à nos forces de sécurité
qu'ils s'exposaient lutte au quotidien
mais aujourd'hui comme législateur notre
responsabilité est toute particulière
tenter de rendre plus efficace larmes
judiciaire contre le terrorisme et plus
particulièrement protéger nos
compatriotes d'un risque de récidive
terroristes vaste ambition nous voilà
avec ce texte cela était déjà dit devant
une difficulté le risque de récidive
délinquante relève dans les faits de la
prévision voire de la prédiction et nous
parlons avec ce texte d'ordonner des
sanctions nouvelles restrictives de
liberté à des personnes qui condamnés
ont déjà effectué la totalité de leur
peine qui plus est avant que la loi dont
nous débattons ne soit votée et donc
avant leur condamnation
vous même monsieur le garde des sceaux
avait rappelé il ya seulement trois
jours
combien vous étiez opposé en son temps à
la rétention de sûreté durant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy vous
cependant justement à cette sanction
après la sanction car imposer des
mesures restrictives de liberté à un
être humain auquel aucune infraction
n'est imputé simplement de crainte
qu'ils n'en commettent une nouvelle
conduit à quitter le terrain des faits
pour lui diagnostiquent aléatoire au nom
d'un principe de précaution élargi à la
justice pénale
vous l'avez d'ailleurs parfaitement
résumé hier lors de votre audition à la
commission des lois lorsque répondant au
député diard vous avez indiqué attendez
vous des juges des magistrats et du
garde des sceaux qui soit un médium
capable d'endiguer des velléités de
nouvelles infractions
ce n'est que ça la question
et je vais vous dire la sécurité absolue
c'est l'enfermement à vie pour tout le
monde alors là vous n'aurez plus aucun
problème au fil des années des lois des
événements tragiques que notre pays a
connus nous avons créé renforcées ajouté
des modalités de poursuite de sanction
de suivi des personnes coupables de
faits terroristes ce faisant nous avons
mêlé justice administrative et justice
judiciaire juge d'application des peines
parquet suivi socio-judiciaire régime
spécial de réduction des peines est
aujourd'hui nul n'est plus capable
d'évaluer l'efficacité de ces
dispositions
mais chaque majorité veut laisser son
empreinte donner à voir sa détermination
même par un texte inapplicable fragile
au regard de nos principes
constitutionnels devons-nous au sénat
participer à cela je ne crois pas
devons-nous transiger avec les principes
de notre droit la légalité de la peine
notre bis in idem la non rétroactivité
de la loi pénale
je ne crois pas devons-nous tenter
d'éviter la guerre au prix du déshonneur
pour récolter au final et la guerre et
le déshonneur
je ne crois pas le conseil national des
barreaux nous appelle à refuser la peine
après la peine le conseil d'état de
manière assez obscur convenons-en a
tenté d'accepter la qualification de
mesures de sûreté des dispositions
proposées tout en reconnaissant que la
foncière n'était pas net
tout en se montrant très prudent et
c'est un euphémisme sur le dispositif
envisagé
il rappelle de plus que pour l'essentiel
les dispositions contenues dans cette
proposition de loi existe déjà et que la
complexité ça a été rappelée à l'instant
par un de nos collègues qui en
résulteraient pourrait affecter
l'efficacité de la politique de l'état
les propos tenus par votre prédécesseur
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée monsieur
le ministre étaient eux aussi empreint
d'une réserve à peine dissimulée
évoquant la fragile équilibre du texte
et la superposition de mesures
susceptibles d'être appliquées aux mêmes
fins c'est pour ces motifs je le dis
aujourd'hui et je l' annonce au sénat
que le groupe socialiste saisira le
conseil constitutionnel de ce texte une
fois voté aux fins d'examen de sa
conformité à l'état de droit
votre prédécesseur rappelé devant
l'assemblée la nécessité d'une
évaluation des dispositifs et
distant alors je le dis de manière un
peu solennel monsieur le ministre
allez vous pour votre premier texte
apposer votre signature sur un texte
tout à la fois en rupture avec nos
principes incantatoire canton ce champ
d'application fictif du point de vue de
l'efficacité de l'action de l'état et de
la lutte contre la récidive et un texte
qui ouvre un précédent auquel il sera
impossible de résister sont uniques et
maigre vertus et d'afficher sur le plan
politique que cette majorité agit contre
le risque terroriste
comme si ces quelques mots un seul
article de loi valait démonstration
monsieur le garde des sceaux le 17
juillet lors de votre déplacement au
tribunal judiciaire de paris
vous disiez un journalistes
l'accompagnant d'un geste illustratif de
la main voyez-vous monsieur il y a une
toute petite règle dans notre
constitution
dans notre république une petite bricole
se faisait ce geste là qui s'appelle la
constitution pour notre part nous
succombons pas et défendons coûte que
coûte dans ces périodes difficiles les
principes fondateurs de notre état de
droit
et comme l'a dit dans cet hémicycle en
2008 robert badinter sénateur au sujet
de la rétention de sûreté
l'homme dangereux va désormais remplacé
l'homme coupable devant notre justice
avec ce texte nous y sommes voilà
pourquoi le groupe socialiste votera
contre ce texte
merci la parole est à monsieur le garde
des sceaux seul ministre
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais
répondre à madame la sénatrice assassi à
monsieur le sénateur leconte à madame la
sénatrice de la gontrie jeu je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure nous sommes sur une ligne
de crête ce constat dé facto exclu les
vociférations compassionnel tant il est
vrai d'ailleurs que tout ce qui est
excessif n'est pas crédible
vous avez rappelé mes propos d'hier si
la répression féroce c'était la garantie
de la rémission des crimes
pardon il y à des siècles des siècles
que ça se saurait alors évidemment c'est
vous et sur le sujet non on peut aussi
réfléchir et je vais vous dire et je
vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai bougé sur
le sujet non laissez moi laissez moi
vous répondre sans être interrompu vous
pourrez considérer que mon cheminement
intellectuel n'est pas le fruit d'une
vérité que je vais vous soumettre à
l'instant j'ai fait part de ses
réflexions à monsieur le président bas
et je voudrais vous soumettre mes
réflexions
j'étais totalement opposées totalement
opposé à la rétention de sûreté
en ce que on ne renfermait pas un homme
pour ce qu'il avait fait mais à raison
de ce que put hâtivement qu'il pouvait
faire j'ai à l'esprit aussi cette
formule que nous connaissons tous de
benjamin franklin qui dit qu'un peuple
qui est prêt à sacrifier un peu de sa
liberté pour un peu de sécurité ne
mérite ni l'une ni l'autre et finit par
perdre les deux mes premières réflexions
il ne s'agit pas ici d'une détention
pardon et ces singulières un nom
différent deuxième réflexion
le juge de l'ordre judiciaire garant de
la liberté et est associée à ce
placement sous bracelet qui je le
rappelle n'est pas obligatoire et
justement ça change tout parce que
dans quelle situation se trouve monsieur
le sénateur le sais moi répond j'en ai
pour deux secondes dans quelle situation
se trouve tant aujourd'hui dans quelle
situation se trouve temps si cette loi
n'est pas votée
un terroriste condamné sort il va faire
l'objet d'une surveillance par les
services de renseignement surveillance
pardon qui peut être attentatoire à sa
liberté
on va pouvoir l'écouter dans des
conditions que nous savons autorisations
administratives bien moi je préfère que
cela se fasse sous le contrôle du juge
judiciaire
et voilà pourquoi après avoir mûrement
réfléchi à tout cela je suis évidemment
favorable à ces nouvelles dispositions
voilà c'est pas plus compliqué que ça ça
n'est pas avalé des son chapeau parce
que je suis devenu ministre vous si vous
ne faites pas la différence pardon entre
une rétention alors moi je disais à
l'époque je me souviens des mots que
j'ai prononcés à l'époque ce dimanche
vous vous dites que ce n'est pas une
nouvelle peine enfin le type reste dans
la même cellule
il va manger la même gamelle pardonner
cette familiarité
il va avoir les mêmes gardiens de prison
vous venez que ça n'est pas une
privation de liberté on fait quand même
bien le distinguo vous et moi entre le
bracelet facultatif facultatif et la
prison et l'emprisonnement voilà
pourquoi je suis favorable
alors je veux dire gg il ya une autre
réflexion qu'on aurait pu conduire
je ne les ai pas entendus ici c'est sur
l'efficacité certains pourront me dire
oui ça n'est pas très efficace
d'ailleurs ce malheureux prêtre qui a
été égorgé lorette est et de ce que je
sais par un homme qui portait un
bracelet certes mais ya peut-être un
certain nombre d'infractions qui ne
seront pas commise à raison du port de
se passer et ce chiffre là pardon de
vous le dire nous le connaîtrons
évidemment jamais voilà voilà voilà
pourquoi je je je redis qu'on est sur la
crête
je sais que toutes ces questions de
liberté sont des questions absolument
essentiel voilà ma position je vous en
fais pas c'est un cheminement long
cheminement
mais je fais le distinguo et je vous
demande de le faire entre le bracelet
électronique et la prison
merci monsieur le ministre la discussion
générale est close et nous passons à la
discussion du texte de la commission
à l'article 1er pardon monsieur le
président bah je vous en prie excusez
moi je vous remercie puisque nous
abordons maintenant la discussion des
articles
je veux revenir sur plusieurs points qui
ont paru essentiel à la commission parce
que personne ne peut nier que la
démarche dans laquelle nous sommes
engagés est une démarche délicate
il s'agit d'être particulièrement
attentifs à des anciens condamnés qui
ont purgé leur peine et qui sont donc en
règle avec la justice mais qui peuvent
présenter une forte dangerosité et d'un
autre côté la liberté que tout citoyen a
le droit de pouvoir exercer à partir du
moment où il est en règle avec la
justice c'est donc très délicat comme
démarche
et si nous nous sommes engagés dans
cette démarche ça n'est pas sans prendre
un certain nombre de précautions
je suis d'ailleurs très heureux que
notre collègue de l'assemblée nationale
l'auteur de la proposition de loi madam
michelle braun pie v qui s'est
d'ailleurs je pense aspirer de nos
propres travaux quand elle a rédigé son
texte et pris la précaution de le
soumettre au conseil d'état lequel a
rendu un avis circonstancié de 13 pages
qui n'est pas un brevet de
constitutionnalité et de conventionalité
qui soulève un certain nombre de
problèmes lesquels ont été examinés par
plusieurs de nos collègues mais qui
montre aussi le chemin possible pour
permettre de concilier les deux
exigences que j'ai rappelé celle de la
liberté et celle de la protection de la
société
je crois que il faut reprendre très
précisément les choses parce que ce
n'est pas avec des incantations ou des
réquisitions que nous allons régler le
problème de cette proposition de loi
mais en étant précis sur les
dispositions qui sont prises la nature
des restrictions liberté qu'ils seraient
autorisés
et les garanties qui sont apportées pour
que ces restrictions ne soient pas
excessives
il ya plusieurs points qu'il faut
examiner le premier point c'est est ce
qu'on est entré avec cette proposition
de loi dans un régime qui consisterait à
faire en sorte qu'ils aient un condamné
qui a purgé sa peine soit de nouveau
condamné pour les mêmes faits pour le
même crime ou pour le même délit
alors là mes chers collègues je veux
absolument vous rassurer la réponse est
non et il n'y a pas de nuances à cette
réponse ce qui est prévu c'est bien le
respect de cette règle essentielle de
l'étape droit non bis in idem
parce que il s'agit d'une mesure de
surveillance et non pas de rétention le
garde des sceaux vient de le rappeler
il s'agit d'une mesure donc qui ne prive
pas de sa liberté
l'ancien condamné mais qui restreint
cette liberté il s'agit d'une mesure
aussi d'accompagnement psychologique et
social dont la mise en oeuvre va être
assurée par le service pénitentiaire de
l'insertion et de la probation dont la
vocation est d'accompagner les anciens
détenus dans la démarche de réinsertion
il s'agit d'une mesure par conséquent
qui laisse sa liberté mais peut inciter
l'individu à faire les démarches
nécessaires professionnels deux
formations de soutien psychologique qui
vont contribuer à faciliter sa
réinsertion est bien de telles mesures
ne peuvent en aucun cas être interprété
comme des peines et le travail
spécifique de la commission des lois du
sénat et de notre rapporteur a consisté
à renforcer le caractère de mesures de
surveillance et d'accompagnement du
dispositif proposé par la proposition de
loi donc je crois qu'il faut cesser de
considérer les mesures proposées comme
constitutif d'une peine parce que elles
n'en sont pas le deuxième point qui me
paraît vraiment très important c'est
d'apprécier si oui ou non
il est nécessaire d'intervenir
aujourd'hui par la loi parce que vous
l'avez rappelé plusieurs d'entre vous il
y à d'autres dispositifs
alors voyons très précisément 6 et
autres dispositifs sont pertinents si
nous permettront de réaliser cette
conciliation entre la protection de la
société et la liberté de quelqu'un qui a
purgé sa peine
moi je crois que la loi de 2015 sur le
renseignement dont j'ai eu l'honneur
d'être le rapporteur devant vous la loi
qui a institué à l'automne 2017 les
mesures individuelles de contrôle
administratif et de surveillance et la
loi de 2016 contre le terrorisme ne
répondent pas à la préoccupation qui est
la nôtre quand nous défendons cette
proposition de loi je reproche à chacune
de ces textes en commençant par le
dernier précisément la loi de 2016
contre le terrorisme a prévu au moment
où on prononce la condamnation de
prévoir la mesure de sûreté
et donc ceux qui ont été condamnés avant
l'entrée en vigueur de cette loi ne
peuvent faire l'objet des mesures
prévues par cette loi
donc cette loi n'est pas pertinente pour
régler le problème des quelque 150
condamné qui vont être libérés en 2020
2021 et 2022
nous avons besoin d'un autre dispositif
alors est-ce que nous pouvons nous
contenter des mesures individuelles de
contrôle administratif et de
surveillance qui ont été prévus
temporairement par la loi que qui a
permis de sortir de l'état d'urgence
pour la lutte contre le terrorisme à
l'automne 2017
eh bien je dois répondre en réalité que
ces lois n'ont pas le même objet d'abord
dans les mesures de surveillance qui
sont prévues il n'y a pas de mesures
d'accompagnement à la réinsertion
on ne se donne pas la chance d'essayer
au moins de ramener à une vie normale
un ancien condamné pour complicité de
terrorisme est donc déjà ce dispositif
est un dispositif qui ne couvre que
partiellement les finalités
que nous voulons réaliser la deuxième
chose c'est qu'en réalité les mesures de
surveillance qui sont prévues par cette
loi de 2017
elles sont plus sévère encore que celle
que nous proposons nous pourrons
d'ailleurs permettre à l'état d'y
recourir
elles sont à la fois plus sévère parce
qu'elles permettent l'assignation à
résidence est parce qu elles peuvent
imposer un pointage quotidien dans les
services de police ou de gendarmerie
et elles sont de nature administrative
c'est à dire que le juge nanterrien pas
eh bien nous nous proposons pour
améliorer les garanties offertes de
respect des libertés qu'au lieu de
prendre des mesures purement
administrative ce soit des mesures
judiciaires est contrôlé par une
juridiction qui soit appliquée ainsi on
protège mieux les libertés que si on
s'en remettait purement et simplement
comme certains d'entre vous paraissent
l'avoir suggéré aux mesures d'ordre
administratif que notre arsenal
juridique prévoit il ya enfin la loi sur
le renseignement
mais je connais bien cette loi on en a
parlé tout à l'heure mais elle mobilise
des moyens extrêmement important est-ce
qu'il n'est pas plus raisonnable de
prendre une mesure de surveillance et
d'accompagnement pour les anciens
condamnés ayant purgé leur peine
et dans l'hypothèse où il se
conduiraient d'une manière qui
renforcerait les soupes sion de risque
de récidive
à ce moment là de mobiliser des moyens
de surveillance complémentaire très fort
très intense qui demande est également
une bonne mobilisation importante de
personnel je crois en réalité que la
nécessité de la loi que nous allons
débattre
elle est entièrement contenue quand on
compare les dispositifs existants avec
celui que cette proposition de loi a
suggéré de mettre en place
enfin est-ce que les mesures sont
proportionnées et bien je crois qu'elle
le saut en effet elles sont moins
restrictive que d'autres j'ai essayé de
le démontrer avec une garantie
judiciaire qui n'existe pas pour les
mesures administratives et par contre
par conséquent
on peut considérer en effet qu'elles
sont à la fois proportionnée nécessaire
et respectueuse de la règle non bis in
idem je crois que si nous nous en tenons
à ces constatations nous devrons adopter
ce texte avec les amendements qui ont
été proposées par notre rapporteur
merci monsieur le président donc nous
examinons à l'article 1er un amendement
3 rectifié bis et c'est monsieur gold
qui va nous le présenter jozan prix
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre dans le cadre de l'examen de
cette proposition de loi les magistrats
auditionné en souligner à quel point la
définition de la particulière
dangerosité est difficile pour justifier
la mise en place de mesures de sûreté
l'issue de la peine la probabilité très
élevée de récidive
un des critères cumulatifs retenu est
elle même très difficile à évaluer et
sept mentions semble surabondante
regarde la finalité du dispositif
explicitée par le même linéaire
l'autre critère l'adhésion persistance à
une idéologie ou à des thèses incitant
la commission d'actes de terrorisme
n'est guère plus satisfaisant comment se
mesure une telle adhésion par des faits
par des prises de positions dans le
premier cas compte tenu de la privation
de liberté de la personne incarcérée il
sera difficile de recueillir des
éléments tels que la consultation
régulière de sites promouvant le
terrorisme ou la participation à la
préparation d'attentats dans le second
cas sur l'adhésion est dissimulé est
donc très difficile à établir
soit elle est explicité et peut donc
faire l'objet d'une nouvelle
condamnation pour être efficaces ces
mesures nécessitent en outre le
déploiement de moyens importants dans
leur enseignement pénitentiaire et dans
les juridictions
l'amendement vise donc à soutenir
l'objectif partagé par les auteurs de la
proposition de loi de renforcer la prise
en charge des personnes condamnées pour
des faits de terrorisme mais considère
que ces dispositions sont de nature à
complexifier des outils judiciaires et
administratifs existants un renforcement
des moyens à l'appui des dispositifs
existants devraient donc être recherché
avant toute nouvelle modification
législative
madame la rapporteure qu'il est de
l'avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
chers collègues c'est vrai que la scène
nationale comme le sénat se sont
efforcés de caractériser évidemment le
plus précisément possible la notion de
particulière dangerosité
afin d'éviter évidemment tout risque
d'arbitraire le texte de la commission
propose un équilibre à la fois
opérationnelles et sécurisé ans sur le
plan constitutionnel donc votre un
moment vise effectivement à remettre en
cause tout ce travail que nous avons
mené pour effectivement apporté une
définition la plus proche possible hélas
pu en tout cas applicable possible donc
en supprimant les caractères permettant
d'établir la dangerosité d'une personne
il laisse aux autorités judiciaires
une très large un très large pouvoir
d'appréciation est en tout cas il me
semble que c'est la fragilise fortement
la mesure sur le plan constitutionnel
donc je vous demanderais soin de retirer
votre amendement de casiers men avis
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement sur cet
amendement proposait un amendement
tendant à supprimer la définition de ce
qui caractérise la particulière
dangerosité des personnes pouvant faire
l'objet de ces nouvelles mesures de
sûreté
cette définition me semble pourtant
indispensable en effet la
caractérisation de la dangerosité est un
élément central du nouveau dispositif
puisqu'elle permettra le prononcé de
mesures restrictives de liberté à
l'encontre de personnes qui ont terminé
d'exécuter leur peine
à raison de la menace grave pour l'ordre
public qu'elle présente
c'est la raison pour laquelle il
apparaît nécessaire de définir le plus
précisément possible
comment cette dangerosité doit être
appréciée par les juridictions diront à
se prononcer sur ces nouvelles mesures
de sûreté
j'aimais donc un avis défavorable à cet
amendement
ça le compte pour une explication de
vote
oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux j'ai évoqué ce sujet tout à
l'heure dans la discussion générale mais
je vais faire quelques précisions parce
que il me semble que pour caractériser
de dangerosité
il faudra qu'il y ait il y aura un
contradictoires comment garantir ce
contradictoires et l'efficacité de ce
contradictoire dès lors que une partir
des sources voudront être protégé une
partie des informations qui
permettraient de dire que la personne
effectivement représenter un risque
viennent nos services de renseignement
et ne seront pas les mettre en
expliquant d'où ça vient comment il l'a
obtenu et si à chaque fois c'est la même
chose quelle est l'efficacité de ce type
de mesure donc garantir le
contradictoire
je suis sûr que vous y êtes attaché mais
je pense qu'en garantissant le
contradictoire
bah on
cette mesure est mort tenait pour
laquelle il
cet article n'a aucun sens s'il n'y a
pas d'autre de ce ministre je vous en
prie d'autres est très brièvement
je crois que sur le sénateur qui a une
évaluation qui dure six semaines des
psychologues des psychiatres
ça permet quand même d'avoir une base de
réflexion sur la façon dont on peut
caractériser une dangerosité
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que ça se
passe pour les droits communs ils font
l'objet d'une matière criminelle
expertise psychiatrique et psychologique
obligatoire et vous avez parfois dans
les conclusions du psychiatre du
psychologue voire des deux un certain
nombre de choses qui sont dites sur la
dangerosité de de l'accusé donc voilà ce
qui permet d'évaluer les choses et puis
ensuite il ya le contradictoire et puis
ensuite il ya ce que dit l'intéressé
lui-même parce que s'il persiste à dire
qu'il est toujours dans cette idéologie
il y avait plus de discussions sur la
dangerosité pardonnez moi
monsieur gold vous avez demandé la
parole pour une explication de vote ont
tout simplement pour y en as président
que je retiens ce moment merci le 3
rectifié be s'est retiré nous examinons
toujours à l'article 1er un amendement
numéro un c'est madame grès homme qui va
nous michel gréaume qui va nous
présenter merci madame la présidente
madame la rapporteure monsieur le
président bas monsieur le garde des
sceaux chaque collègue comme madame
assassi présidente de notre groupe l'a
souligné tout à l'heure la nit l'alinéa
17 correspond à l'une des onze mesures
de sûreté possible que peut ordonner la
juridiction régionale de la rétention de
sète sur hot et sur réquisition du
procureur de la république et qui
consiste pour le condamné qui a purgé sa
peine à se présenter périodiquement au
service de police ou ou aux unités de
gendarmerie
dans la limite de trois fois par semaine
si bien d'autres mesures sont
contestables sans parler de la logique
globale du système qui nous est proposé
nous estimons qu'il s'agit là d'une des
mesures les plus attentatoires à nos
libertés fondamentales notamment celle
d'aller et venir
comment penser pouvoir et acéré pardon
dans notre société des individus
condamnés pour de tels faits en les
obligeant possiblement pendant plusieurs
années à se rendre jusqu'à trois fois
par semaine dans un commissariat pour
justifier leur présence soit un jour sur
deux pratiquement je le répète il s'agit
là d'un obstacle évident à la reprise
d'une vie active et socialisante en
outre je dois dire que ce millefeuille
de mesures tantôt administrative tantôt
judiciaire des mesures individuelles de
contrôle administratif au suivi
socio-judiciaire en passant par les
nouvelles mesures de sûreté que propose
ce texte est nuisible à la bonne
compréhension du système dans sa
globalité et de notre politique pénale
en la matière le conseil d'état lui même
semble perplexe un décor dans son avis
que la complexité peut aussi nuire à
l'est
efficacité de l'action de l'état prise
dans ses fonctions administratives et
judiciaires
lorsqu'elle appelle l'intervention
d'autorité ou de services différents
entre lesquels la nécessaire coopération
reste à construire
il faudra monsieur le garde des sceaux
que vous nous éclairer
de manière assez précise sur les
subtilités qui différencie l'ensemble de
ces mesures et sur leurs cours et
cohérence finale merci c'est pourquoi
nous demandons de retirer cet alinéa
merci merci madame la rapporteure quel
est l'avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
moi je voudrais juste dire deux mots à
notre collègue
je pense que nous parlons de personnes
qui hectos qui ont été condamnés pour
terrorisme qui sont donc rentrés dans
une idéologie spa rien de le dire et je
pense que le contrôle il est essentiel
ce qu'on souhaite tous c'est que ces
personnes retrouvent le chemin normal de
la vie ça c'est aucun souci avec ça sauf
que sauf que personne ici ne peut
mesurer le degré de déradicalisation et
comment ils ont pu échapper à citer de
logis qui les amenait à les actes quand
même qu'on ne veut pas oublier donc le
contrôle
il permet quoi il permet de temps en
temps de mesurer soit une situation qui
s'aggrave
soit une situation qui s'améliore en
termes d'adhésion cette idéologie et
rien d'autre qu'un contrôle rien d'autre
qu'à contact physique permet de le faire
c'est juste ça donc bien évidemment nous
proposerons un avis défavorable à cet
amendement
monsieur le ministre quel est l'avis du
gouvernement sur cet amendement
madame la sénatrice
votre amendement tend à supprimer
l'obligation de pointage puis je vous
rappeler que cette mesure est toujours
révisable à la demande de l'intéressé et
que c'est un juge de l'ordre judiciaire
qui statue
je suis donc vous l'avez compris dès cet
instant totalement défavorable à cette
suppression
yat-il madame madame grès hommes pour
n'est qu'une explication de vote
excusez moi je vous ai bien entendu je
vous comprends quand vous me parlez de
contrôle je comprends tout à fait sauf
qu'il ya différentes façons que vous
pouvez contrôler contrôler quand si une
personne on veut qu'elle soit réinsérer
dans la vie actuelle
quelle part travailler ou qu'elle parte
en phase où vous pouvez voir si elle est
là ou pas y at il d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas joe biden initiaux en
prix du mois mais le travail effectif la
socialisation
ce sont des éléments que le juge prendra
forcément en considération on préfère
avoir un ancien islamiste radical qui
travaillent qui serait un cerf que
quelqu'un qui est dans l'oisiveté donc
ça sont des éléments objectifs que le
juge peut et doit prendre en
considération évidemment donc trois fois
c'est le maximum c'est révisable il ya
un juge de l'ordre judiciaire qui
contrôle ça je vais mettre voit cet
abandon avec deux avis défavorables qui
est pour son adoption
qui est contre et n'est pas adopté nous
examinons à présent l'amendement 4
rectifié bis c'est monsieur gold qui va
nous présenter je vous en prie merci
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
chers collègues le présent amendement
vise à rétablir à durée initiale des
mesures de sûreté susceptible d'être
prononcée à l'issue de la peine à un an
comme prévu par les auteurs la
proposition de loi madame la rapporteure
quel est l'avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
juste rappeler que effectivement c'est
la commission des lois du sénat qui a
procédé à cet allongement
afin de rendre ce dispositif à notre
sens plus opérationnel et suit surtout à
des auditions que nous avons mené la
durée d'un an imposerait en effet
d'initier le renouvellement de la mesure
des son monde dès son prononcé
pratiquement avant même que ne puisse
être apprécié l'évolution de la personne
concernée sûr que voilà l'évaluation se
ferait sur un temps très court
voilà donc c'est ce qui nous a posé
problème donc j'ajouterai que la durée
deux ans ne sont pas disproportionnées
par rapport aux dispositifs existants
par exemple la surveillance de sûreté
ainsi elle aussi peut être prononcée
pour une durée initiale de deux ans donc
pour ces raisons j'émets un avis
défavorable à votre
amendement monsieur me dise quel est
l'avis du gouvernement sur cet
amendement vous proposer un amendement
ayant pour objet de rétablir la durée
initiale de la mesure de sûreté à une
durée d'un an
la commission des lois du sénat a fait
choix d'augmenter la durée initiale de
la mesure de sûreté à deux ans si je
comprends les préoccupations
opérationnelle qui l'ont conduite à
retenir cette durée je pense qu'une
telle augmentation pourrait fragiliser
la solidité juridique du dispositif
d'un point de vue opérationnel les
mesures de sûreté ne pourront être
renouvelées qu'après une évaluation
pluridisciplinaire de la dangerosité de
la personne condamnée et à l'issue d'un
débat contradictoire au cours duquel la
personne condamnée sera obligatoirement
assisté par un avocat ça représente en
effet des contraintes pour
l'administration pénitentiaire et pour
l'autorité judiciaire néanmoins le
renouvellement régulier de la mesure par
l'autorité judiciaire constitue une
garantie importante pour assurer une
conciliation équilibrée entre la
prévention la prévention pardonnez-moi
des atteintes à l'ordre public et le
principe selon lequel la liberté
personnelle ne serait être entravée par
une rigueur non nécessaire à titre de
comparaison les mesures individuelles de
contrôle administratif et de
surveillance ont été déclarés conformes
à la constitution sont prononcés pour
une durée initiale de trois mois
pour ces raisons je suis favorable à cet
amendement qui permet de revenir à une
durée initiale d'un non monsieur le
comte pour une explication de vote il
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux cet amendement là aussi
soulignant une difficulté parce que
j'étais présent au moment des auditions
de madame la rapporteure et nous savons
pourquoi elle a présenté cet amendement
je ne souhaite pas défendre ce ces
dispositions après ce que j'ai dit en
discussion générale mais ça une certaine
logique dans la mesure où il nous a été
expliqué que pour
pouvoir faire une deuxième année de
mesures de sûreté
il fallait en réalité engagé une demande
de renouvellement dans les deux ou trois
mois maximum qui suivait la libération
de la personne et que par conséquent
c'était quand même très compliqué c'est
la raison pour laquelle la rapporteur a
fait ça mais ça montre aussi que ce
système est complètement bancal surtout
que monsieur le garde des sceaux tout à
l'heure quand je vous posais la question
de la dangerosité la dangerosité
là encore on nous avons énormément de
témoignages qui nous ont dit oui
dans le cas des délinquants sexuels
effectivement une évaluation
psychiatrique
on peut considérer qu'elle qu'elle
correspond effectivement une évaluation
nécessaire mais dans le cas de situation
de d'anciens condamnés pour terrorisme
ce n'est pas pareil et ce n'est pas
aussi simple et ce sont d'autres
éléments d'information qui mérite d'être
pris en compte donc finalement cet
amendement souligne la fragilité du
dispositif et le fait qu'on ne peut pas
compter sur ce type de mesures qui
portent deux fronts nos principes
républicains et du principe d' état de
droit on ne peut pas compter sur ce type
de mesures pour assurer une meilleure
sécurité qu'obtenu finalement de toutes
les contraintes qui pèsent sur cela
madame de la gontrie pour une
explication de vote je vous en prie
merci madame la présidente
il faut qu'on est bien à l'esprit la
temporalité dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons ce qui est très fier très jeu
vous le dit monsieur le garde est ce que
c'est
visiblement votre conseiller est
absolument passionnant mais du coup
c'est très troublant quand on essaye de
vous convaincre enfin bon bah oui mais
moi vous savez je fais une petite chose
fragile j'essaye de convaincre
je disais donc que la temporalité est la
suivante nous sommes au cours de la
détention c'est à ce moment là que
l'examen a lieu tout à l'heure monsieur
le garde des sceaux a dit quelque chose
qui était qui m'a troublé parce que ce
n'est pas ce que j'avais compris du
texte il a fait référence à une
expertise mais que je sache il n'y en a
pas c'est bien d'ailleurs tout le
problème c'est qu'il y a une espèce de
deux nébuleuses d'indications qui permet
éventuellement aux magistrats de penser
que et il n'ya il ya une grande
difficulté d'objectivation de la
circonstance
alors cet amendement propose de réduire
à un an et je pense que c'est normal
parce que dans ce texte qui déjà est
complexe il est expliqué qu' il faudra
s'appuyer sur des éléments actuels et
circonstanciée donc nécessairement les
éléments actuels et circonstanciée ce ne
sont pas des éléments qui se tiennent
deux ans plus tard j'indique puisqu'il
n'y aura pas d' expertise que ce sera
sur la base de témoignages qui seront
les témoignages des chefs de détention
donc tout ça on quand même le
l'opération assez complexe et pour le
coup je pense qu'il faut absolument que
nous réduisions à un an de manière à ce
qu'il y ait un réexamen régulier vous
l'avez dit monsieur le garde des sceaux
d'ailleurs va geler compris comme cela
un réexamen régulier et contradictoires
de la situation tous les ans et non pas
tous les besoins
monsieur de belles années pour une
explication de vote
oui merci ma présidente nous un jeu
votre et cet amendement j'entends
l'objectif poursuivi par la commission
qui est celui de l'efficacité de
l'opérationnalité il est tout à fait ton
temps
je partage avec l'orateur du groupe
socialiste tout à l'heure la
préoccupation que ceux de ce que ce
texte ne soit pas sanctionné au regard
de la constitution et le principe de
proportionnalité par cet amendement me
semble consolider et je m'étonne qu'on
puisse nous dire en discussion générale
au plateau engagé un recours devant le
juge constitutionnel et tergiversé
lorsque le garde des sceaux nous nous
indique un avis favorable à cet
amendement qui sécurise
constitutionnellement les choses je note
que notre collègue est très sensible aux
interventions ou à l'oreille du ministre
à l'attention de ses conseillers et à
laquelle je m'adressais particulièrement
préfère discuter avec son collègue ou
aussi une petite chose fragile cher que
la
y at il d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote
je n'en vois pas je vais mettre où va
cet amendement avec un avis défavorable
de la commission et un avis favorable du
gouvernement
quai pour son adoption qui est contre il
n'est pas adopté je vais mettre aux voix
l'article 1er y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas qu'est pour son
adoption
qui est contre l'article est adoptée
après l'article premier article
additionnel un amendement numéro deux
c'est madame benbassa qui va nous
présenter
merci madame la présidente si quartier
d'évaluation de la radicalisation ont
été mis en place à partir de 2016 sur
tout le territoire
l'évaluation dure quatre mois pendant
lesquels il est procédé à de longs
entretiens éducateurs psychologues
référents religieux religieux conseiller
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation intervienne afin de croiser
les regards sur la situation et
l'évolution des condamnés en ce sens
l'ensemble des personnels de
l'administration pénitentiaire
participent à des formations spécifiques
construite sur la thématique de la
radicalisation violente
le but est de dévaluer le niveau de
notre thé du détenu et sa potentielle
capacité de dissimulation cette pratique
étant répandue chez les personnes
radicaliser viennent ensuite
l'évaluation du niveau de dangerosité
la probabilité d'un passage à un acte
violent puis le niveau de prosélytisme
à la suite de ces évaluations les
personnes en craie dans un processus de
radicalisation violente présentant une
forte imprégnation idéologique et
prosélyte sont affectés en quartier de
pluie en charge de la radicalisation
récupère
étanche du reste de la détention cela
concerne 15 % des détenus de qr face à
tout ce dispositif dans les rouages
semble pourtant bien huilée on nous
propose aujourd'hui de mettre en place
de nouveaux ce sas d'observation dans
lesquelles les détenus seront évalués
six semaines afin de déterminer leur
niveau de dangerosité et les mesures de
sûreté qui leur seront assignés
lorsqu'ils ne seront plus écroué il
apparaît évident que regarde la teneur
de cette proposition de loi
les qr comme les qpr ne remplissent pas
les objectifs pour lesquels ils ont été
créés autrement dit ces mesures du
succès semble symptomatique de l'échec
de la mise en oeuvre de ses quartiers
dans l'eau sans pénitentiaire depuis
2016 qu'en est il réellement
c'est ce que nous souhaitons comprendre
en demandant la remise au parlement d'un
tel rapport qui nous permettrait à la
fois de dresser les causes de cet échec
et d'en tirer toutes les conséquences
pour l'avenir et l'amélioration du
système dans son ensemble
madame la rapporteure qu'il est l'avis
de la commission sur cet amendement
chers collègues c'est vrai que nous
sommes un certain nombre à se poser des
interrogations sur ces faits mais qu air
mais voilà on n'a pas toutes les données
mais en tout cas je rappelle que en tout
cas c'est la position de la commission
que les rapports au parlement ne
constitue pas pour nous le meilleur
moyen pour les parlements d'exercer son
pouvoir de contrôle donc nous et je
souhaite émettre un avis défavorable à
votre amendement monsieur le ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement
madame la sénatrice où vous proposer un
amendement ayant pour objet de prévoir
la remise par le gouvernement au
parlement d'un rapport analysant et
évaluant la mise en oeuvre des quartiers
d'évaluation de la radicalisation et des
quartiers de prise en charge de la
radicalisation
de manière générale le gouvernement
n'est pas favorable à la multiplication
des rapports
le parlement dispose déjà de multiples
moyens d'information et de contrôle de
l'activité du gouvernement et je suis
par conséquent défavorable aux présentes
amendements y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je vais mettre aux voix
cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté je
vais mettre aux voix
l'article 1er bis y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas qui est pour son
adoption
qui est contre il est adopté l'article 2
qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre il est adopté à l'article
3 nous avons un amendement numéro 5 de
notre rapporteur que j'invite à nous
présenter
oui quelques secondes c'est un
amendement de coordination qui vise à
tenir compte de l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi visant à protéger les victimes de
violences conjugales dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure
l'ong monsieur le ministre quel est
l'avis du gouvernement sur cet
amendement
je vais je vais mettre voit cet
amendement avec un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre il est adopté et
l'amendement est ainsi le port dont
l'article est ainsi rédigé je vais
mettre aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote monsieur sûr je vous en prie merci
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues
oui nous voulons tous lutter contre le
terrorisme
nous récusons toutefois toute démagogie
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre c'est
vrai si on enfermait tout le temps tout
le monde tous ceux qui sont en prison
il y aurait peut-être une sécurité
je ne sais pas mais nous récusons la
démagogie
alors qu'y at il aux termes de ce texte
on nous a beaucoup fait sonner le
bracelet électronique
mais il y un point sur lequel tout le
monde est d'accord c'est que le bracelet
électronique ne peut exister que si la
personne consent à le porter donc si la
personne dit non ce moyen n'a pas
d'effet il n'existe purement et
simplement pas d'autre part il ya des
mesures se présenter au commissariat la
gendarmerie
mais elles sont déjà dans les mika les
mesures individuelles le contrôle
administratif et de surveillance vous
avez dit qu'elle existait même monsieur
le président vous avez dit qu'elle était
sévère et je pense que votre
gouvernement monsieur le ministre pour
aller reconduire
alors que reste-t-il finalement et qui
est sûre qui peut dire que parce qu'une
personne ira pointer le lundi au
commissariat
elle ne commettra pas quels délits tels
crimes le mardi ou le mercredi
tout ça est compliqué monsieur le
ministre et d'ailleurs vous le savez
mieux que quiconque et par conséquent
nous pensons qu'il y a un vrai chemin
très difficile ce chemin s'est d'abord
l'accompagnement des personnes qui
sortent de prison
quel qu'il soit et par conséquent la
préparation à la sortie ce moyen c'est
donner plus de moyens aux services de
renseignement et n'ayant pas peur de le
dire car vous savez bien mais chaque
collègue que le meilleur moyen pour
éviter la récidive turin terrorisme
c'est d'abord le renseignement
ne nous racontons pas d'histoires et
puis c'est aussi la condition
pénitentiaire et la déradicalisation en
prison c'est le contraire qui se passe
actuellement et nous le savons tous
alors je ne peux pas être plus long mais
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez dit
qu'au terme de ces décennies de
réflexion que vous menez sur la justice
vous aviez effectué un cheminement
j'ai un peu peur que le cheminement soit
un raccourci un peu tardif eu et je
pense que d'une certaine façon je
préférais saluer toute la réflexion qui
fut la vôtre je suis sûr que vous la
conduire et vous continuerez car c'est
un grand chemin difficile que de faire
face vous le savez mieux que quiconque à
ces enjeux auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
le cdb l'aîné pour une explication de
vote
merci madame la présidente très très
rapidement le président françois
hollande à propos des pédophiles et des
mesures de sûreté disait il ya quelques
années je ne conçois pas une
demi-seconde
je ne conçois pas il est inconcevable
que des récidivistes en puissance se
promène dans la nature
je ne conçois pas non plus que des
terroristes
récidiviste en puissance se baladent
dans la nature ce texte contribue à
sécuriser le pays
il est sur la ligne de crête il est
équilibré ne nous racontons pas
d'histoires votons le s'il n'y a pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
eh bien je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
instaurant des mesures de sûreté à
l'encontre des auteurs d'infractions
terroristes à l'issue de leur peine qui
est pour son adoption
qui est contre bien la proposition de
loi est adopté
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous avez pu suivre les débats sur
la proposition de loi instaurant des
mesures de sûreté à l'encontre des
auteurs d'infractions terroristes à
l'issue de leur peine
un texte qui a été donc voté hier au
sénat je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver toute l'actualité
parlementaire sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr et je vous souhaite une
excellente journée à tous